donc pour revenir à une question qui m'a
été posée je vais très clair le 1er
décembre les règles de déplacement
l'attestation obligatoire ne changeront
pas par rapport à la situation actuelle
et nous allons tout faire
s'agissant des déplacements en train ou
pas pour les vacances de noël de au fur
et à mesure de l'évolution sainte-terre
préciser ça aux français dans des délais
qui leur permettront de san remo dire je
l'espère d'ici la fin du mois laurent
d'accord donc à ce jour la seule chose
très pédagogique qui pourrait changer si
les conditions sanitaires se confirme
si les protocoles sanitaires aboutissent
c'est que les commerces que nous avons
fermé pendant le confinement pourrait
rouvrir